we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's just
sort of like an ask david personal
advice edition of the voicemail segment
take a listen hey David
my question is how do you cut talks with
people out of your life do you just stop
contacting them or just delete them from
your phone contact list delete them from
your rolodex yeah you just stop talking
to them I I've had an unfortunately high
number of completely toxic people that
have entered my life sometimes directly
but often sort of more tangentially they
enter through another friend for example
and then they start to have this just
very very negative impact on my life and
it doesn't have to be my experience is
that it's better I've I've opted not to
sort of have a conversation and say
listen don't text me anymore don't call
me anymore I can't be involved with you
anymore in in in those direct terms I
just sort of let it Peter out and that I
find is better because some of the most
toxic people also will make your life a
living hell
if you directly tell them please don't
get in touch with me anymore but yeah I
mean it's basically but by your actions
if not words communicating that you just
don't have the time nor the interest nor
nor the availability to be pulled into
that toxic nonsense I and I would do it
sooner than later because there is no
upside to having those people in your
life it's I don't know if it's tough
love or just obvious advice but that's
what you got to do we've got a great
bonus show today Donald Trump is now
touting a Bible literacy classes for
public schools there's an idea we will
talk about Internet addiction treatment
programs in the United States and also
Tom Brokaw's recent comments which have
him in I guess we could call it some hot
water and a whole bunch of ancillary
stuff coming up with Tom Brokaw after he
said that it is necessary for Hispanic
to better assimilate in the United
States all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get instant access to
the bonus show by becoming a member at
WWN pakman.com or by becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show